so I think you said you shelved the film
what well in 1990 we stopped showing it
and kind of went on with our lives John
Hine was married and had was had kids
and I had a job that was my focus and
you know he had a job to him it was just
I'm just saying our lives our priorities
we kind of ran it just we didn't see any
more opportunities to screen it like I
said there were no film festivals that
were taking video that were projecting
video the alternative film festivals
weren't around at the time the New York
underground
I mean Senna family didn't exist on the
New York underground Chicago underground
the regional underground festivals the
the alternative film fest universe
really hadn't kind of come into bloom
and also again it was the video
projection was still in its infancy
somewhat and that's coming really what
you need in order to you need video
projection in a theater to have a
theater a film experience for a video
otherwise you're just watching it on a
monitor and you're in your living room
which is fine that's certainly how I
used to show it have friends over to
watch it we've been fortunate over the
years we've you know we've heard from
people who were in it we have an
informal alumni group maybe 20 25 people
we've had contact with they're all
family we consider them family members
and you know everybody's pretty you know
they all look back on fondness and and
we have nostalgia that they were in this
video and and a lot of the high profile
soundbite people they we know them and
and they're they really have a good
spirit with regard to their
participation in and being in the video
and we even on the DVD we have a where
are they now we have an alumni segment
you can see you can watch the people
today and we have I'll send you that the
link to that you can see what some of
the people are doing we wanted to show
that you know we made a mini documentary
with the people kind of catching up with
who where they are today and how they're
doing this
about 2006 so this is already almost 10
years old but we still hear from people
we have a group
Judas Priest are on record have said
that they Judas Priest have actually
said that they you know that's our you
know they've been asked about it and
have gone on record talking about it and
and and so they're they're you know
cordial and complimentary about it
saying that's our fans I mean I've never
met them but I'm always grateful when I
hear or see that they've said something
in print or in an interview referencing
it so they know it's out there it's part
of their body at work too
you